antoine baudinet bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france je le
disais vous avez été vous même blessé
parce cette grenade pour commencer
pouvez vous nous rappeler nous rappeler
comment vous avez été blessé et quelles
ont été les conséquences de ce drame
pour vous alors j'ai été blessé le 8
décembre dernier donc suite à la manif
dans la manifestation de l'acte iv dg
jaune faut savoir qu'à la base je
n'étais pas allé à cette manifestation
pour manifester auprès d chez les jaunes
mais auprès des écologistes qui
manifestaient en même temps les deux
cortèges se sont mélangés et
effectivement donc j'ai pu rencontrer
beaucoup dit et jaunes qui ont j'ai
découvert et j'ai appris à les connaître
et à me rendre compte qu'ils étaient
très loin de l'image médiatique ont
souhaité en donner dans l'est dans les
médias et voilà je me suis retrouvée
entre entre d'un côté les crs qui
s'était mis d'un côté d'un feu de
barricades qui avait été mis et les
manifestants qui avaient reculé dans une
rue et moi malheureusement j'étais
accompagné d'amis à moi et mon petit
frère et nous avons enfin et je leur ai
dit de rester en arrière le temps que
j'aille voir ce qui se passe et et que
je revienne
alors effectivement je suis jamais
revenu puisque arrivés sur place
bon ben je me suis avancé centraux sans
trop savoir dans quoi
donc moi je aller et quand un objet à
rouler à mes pieds moi j'ai cru
reconnaître effectivement une grenade
lacrymogène il faut savoir que ces
grenades ont quand même la même couleur
que les grenades que les grenadières 4
donc moi j'ai cru qu effectivement
j'avais prendre tout un énorme nuage de
l'action dans la tête parce que
normalement c'est grenade explose en
l'air et donc malheureusement j'ai j'ai
ramassé salade pour les loyers mois et
elle a exposé dans maman alors que vous
inspire aujourd'hui le retrait de ces
grenades dit griefs cat annoncé on
disait cet après midi par christophe
castaner
le retrait pourrait dire
qu'effectivement c'est une victoire
sauf qu'en réalité ce n'est vraiment pas
une puisque malheureusement la guyane 4
est très loin d'être la simple promenade
utilisés dans le cadre des
manifestations qui contient des
explosifs
c'est à dire que monsieur qu'un salaire
à bien ou précisé qu' il y avait des
grenades qui sont qui contienne des
explosifs et il parle de laquelle quatre
et tout ça il n'oublie nous parler
effectivement par exemple de la gêne des
qui elle contient aussi non seulement
l'explosif mais qui en plus
envoi des pavés des petits papiers de de
plastique de caoutchouc qui vont se
loger dans la chair des manifestants
pour leur faire mal réellement et qui
contient 20 g de taux dit dérivés la tnt
que contient ces grenades qui alors que
la guerre quatre ans contient 25 donc on
n'est pas sur une différence énorme
à côté de ça il ya une nouvelle grenade
qui sont qui sont en train d'être
utilisés notamment l'âge et de la gemme
de zèle voilà c'est une des dernières
et malheureusement ils nous ont déjà
fait le coup en fait c'est à dire que il
ya quelques années il avait déclaré donc
la halle à la grenade qui a tué rémy
frais ce qui lui a fait exploser la tête
ils l'ont déclarée interdite et derrière
ils se sont bien gardés effectivement de
nous dire qu'il existait à kiev 4 l'âge
md et peut-être d'autres d'autres arts
ce mail dont je n'ai pas entendu parler
mais voilà donc on voit bien
effectivement que c'est surtout un coup
médiatique en réalité c'est parce qu'en
plus ces grenades la ja il ya deux trois
ans elle avait été déclarée interdite
déclaré trop dangereuse pour être
utilisant manifestation donc ça quand
même faut le savoir et à côté de ça il
avait décidé de continuer à utiliser les
grenats le temps qu'il aurait ceux des
stocks
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui la seule
raison pour laquelle ils ont interdit
ces guerres 4 j'aurais été parce que les
stocks sont écoulés c'est juste ça en
fait tout simplement non pas une annonce
qui est qui est réellement
de bonne foi c'est à dire que c'est lui
selon vous c'est un pur effet d'annoncé
de la part du ministre de l'intérieur
oui complètement c'est à dire que si il
avait s'il avait déclaré qu'il y avait
d'autres grenade la cmd lâché m de zen
qui sont qui sont dangereuses et qui
voit là devrait bientôt être interdite
ou quoi l'agent aurait pu peut-être y
croire mais en réalité on voit bien que
ce n'est pas le cas que ce n'est pas ça
au contraire c'est plutôt l'idée de
regarder on va interdire la guerre
canaux ou pas et tous parce que voilà au
bout tu écoutes mais par contre vu vous
n'êtes pas trop au courant des autres
call and ben celle là par contre on
continue à les utiliser ça et je serais
prêt à parier que d'ici quelques mois on
entend de monsieur k salaires déclarés
interdit que le npd 40
tout en se gardant bien effectivement de
préciser qu'aujourd'hui est testé dans
nos dom tom le crush 44 qui est une arme
qui vise à remplacer le npd 40 qui est
plus puissant plus précis et qui
aujourd'hui est testé effectivement sur
nos territoires d'outre-mer l'eau
personne n'entend jamais parler
merci antoine molinet de nous avoir
répondu je rappelle que vous avez été
blessées un par un tir de grenade ighli
f4 ces grenades dont qui ont été retirés
aujourd'hui par le ministre de
l'intérieur une annonce de